believe it or not around 29 of Jen's
ears say they want to be a YouTube Star
when they grow up crazy to think that
social media influencer has basically
replaced becoming a movie or sports star
but unlike the highly publicized checks
that Elite actors and athletes can
command the compensation for influencers
is much murkier as of 2020 there are
around 38 million YouTube channels and
the top 10 made between 15 and 29
million dollars but there's an
incredibly steep drop-off one study
estimated that you can be in the top
three percent of YouTubers and still
make less than twenty thousand dollars a
year and the top earning accounts on
Instagram all got famous through other
means not organically on the platform in
the words of influencer agent Joe Gallie
finding financial success on these
platforms is about as likely as winning
the lottery